so this is your fourth time here john
yeah do you know what that means
no what does that mean it's exciting
time oh well um justin go ahead and
bring it out it means i'm easy to book
yes you get your official
everything every fourth time you
remember the club you got a jacket i'm
in the club
yes yes let's put this on it looks good
i'm just saying
it's a it's a good jacket i feel like
you wear jackets like this maybe not
with my name on them
i wear a lot of like the bomber size
jacket yeah
yeah it's interesting blake is actually
he was here four times because
he got a jacket and uh nick you know how
you get to be on the show four times you
have to be invited
that many times i'm sorry buddy i'm
sorry nick
okay he's just cooler and busier you
have to be
no here's the thing here's the thing um
he's actually a member of the club too
he got one last time do you wear your
jacket all the time
oh my god yeah all the time that's so
interesting
i feed the chickens in it i feed the
chickens in that
yeah yeah you know what's interesting is
um
nope you left your jacket here in the
green room actually
yeah yeah yeah you actually
you neglected to even throw it away
after leaving the building you still
have it
oh yeah no we've had your jacket here
we're saving it for you
oh there it is i've been looking for
this
yeah the chickens were missing
[Music]
here's the thing you know when you don't
like a gift you like wait till you leave
the building i always throw it away
in here give it away give me a gift bag
every time i leave and i don't want you
to waste it on me the best part is your
people know you well enough that we were
like so
does he remember getting the four times
and he won't remember any of that he
doesn't remember the jacket
i do remember that you let us drink last
time we were on this show
like we had wine or would you like a
drink yes
i'd like you to keep my gifts so maybe
you'll get a drink when you keep my
guests
yup i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever